when you think about it they're just
words
I think it's empowering I think you can
tell a lot about a culture by the way
they curse my mother would hate me for
saying that but I don't [ __ ] care
[Music]
[ __ ] not fit oh [ __ ] yourself I think I
miss you
go [ __ ] yourself bahá'u'lláh [ __ ] you
big thief [ __ ] you
chin got the malady [ __ ] your mother cuz
some luck [ __ ] your mother see photo
[ __ ] yourself
goodra poor or [ __ ] Tara ye [ __ ] last
Tuesday
go [ __ ] yourself la concha lalalaura
[ __ ] or the parrots vagina [ __ ] - go
ma'am
Merida Kolkata eat [ __ ] I'm doc I gotta
go take a [ __ ] such a hot car a piece of
[ __ ] Kusano yo [ __ ] or [ __ ] she pal [ __ ]
or [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] slump a Sukkah [ __ ]
oh yeah
what saggy heart son of dog or [ __ ] put
them in a mall your mom's a [ __ ]
Virginia little [ __ ] [ __ ] and young
crazy [ __ ] oslo malacca gaga yes a key
son of a [ __ ] hijo de puta
son of a [ __ ] he's shot son of a donkey
you're being an ass come dumpster in
daddy huh your mama issue nuru dela she
violet
it's not pretty watching a jackass in a
pomegranate Ashikaga ass violin or
[ __ ] oh ha sperm cuz somewhat
offensive colors your mother's vagina
you daughter of a dog
[Music]